hey guys welcome back to your weekly
dead stream recap and today's dev stream
was kind of jam-packed with a lot of
facts on the info and even a video on
what the game would have looked like
four years ago what they wished it would
look like four years ago kind of like
some CGI film so you guys definitely not
want to miss out on that but before we
get started there was some talk on
reddit about a whiteout happening
last video I talked about what's called
a blackout that happened before and that
they're starting to try again
basically the blackout his board players
stopped playing the game for 24 hours to
get the dev to listen to us
well some guy didn't believe the
blackout was going to help him was fed
up with it so he made it what's called a
whiteout the whiteout was basically the
opposite of what the blackout would be
so the whiteout you basically play as
much as you possibly can that day it's
going to be on June 17th and the players
are instead of not playing the game
they're going to play as much as they
can this is kind of confusing and trust
me it is but basically this whole
commitment part of this community has
been split into believing either the
community is wrong and not the devs or
the devs are wrong and not the community
so it's kind of split and that's for me
I believe that the community is wrong on
this one and that thing that we need to
stop as a community being so toxic
toward each other and the devs that's
all I really have on this topic also
there was a recent server outage for
anyone that was affected but it was not
just for honor it was all of Ubisoft so
as for compensation they're giving us
three days of champagne status so use
that wisely as regarding patch 1.08
which I covered a couple videos ago the
patch isn't coming out for consoles
until tomorrow and peace a may of PC may
have already had it by now I'm not
entirely sure because they do not play
on PC but since now that this talk is
over let's talk about the dead string
for today so first off on the list is
that the quitter penalty is going to
expect it to be releasing next week
Monday for everyone at the same time and
steel is now 30% off in the store so if
you want to go buy some right now now
time to get it and while you're at it
you can use that skill to buy these new
elite outfits that have just been
released for this week's weekly content
which I'll show to you right now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so they are those are the sweet outfits
I do kind of like the night outfit I
feel the Vikings never get any good
outfits that's just a personal opinion
to me but those are going to be costing
7k each so be sure to grab those while
you can and also what I'm going to be
showing you on-screen is what I talked
about today or in the beginning of the
video which was some vaulted footage of
the devs we're showing that they imaged
or that they imagine the foreigner would
look like four years ago
basically during the development they
wish that they could make it looked
great with all the nice graphics but the
reason that it's never going to be like
this is because they used a [ __ ] ton of
CGI to make this video or film but this
was their dream of what they always
wanted it to be but it's obviously never
going to come through because the amount
of CGI used to make this and that the
graphics for any engine in gaming will
not be able to work with that so I'm
just going to keep playing this for the
rest of the video for you guys to watch
and enjoy while I talk over this so
let's get on with the video then next up
is a change to the new step that was
just released with season two defensive
penetration and emerging are they're
changing the values from seventeen to
fifteen percent and then 15 to nine
percent on the secondary slot making it
a bit less useful and then also guard
stance is going to be changing at the
same time for all characters thankfully
because now from what I'm believing the
assassins are probably going to be a lot
slower and then heavy such as you go key
and then lob ring or as is hybrid is
going to be a bit of a faster when
changing guard stance so I'm very glad
that they added this it's going to make
the game a little bit more balanced and
even now next up is some hero changes
first off can say got a buff to his help
splitter and swift strike which are now
uninterruptible unblocked meaning even
if the attack is blocked he can still
continue with this combo without having
to reset it
making him you know and giving him a lot
more options instead of just spamming
the same attack because if you've ever
played as Ken say once you use those
attacks and then they know how to dodge
or block them it's kind of game over
because there's not many other things
you can do besides that next up warding
got a nerf to a shoulder bash making it
cost more stamina to use and then the
timing for shoulder bash cancel into a
guard break is slower making it easier
to move and coming move and then react
to that
move accordingly shinobi also got a nerf
to his kick and the devs changed it so
that you cannot double dodge into a
guard break the stamina cost for the
kick is now increased the kick is also
uninterruptible later in the move so
that you can cancel his kick by hitting
them at the very beginning of the kick
and then finally the kick is also no
longer so that is now longer so that
players can react to it a bit more
easily this is a huge innervation away
and I I feel personally that this was
needed other people might not but I feel
that his kick was a bit too safe for a
fighting game and lastly for the
characters we have warlord and then for
warlord just as throw distance was
reduced so we're not getting carried
across the map 'ln but the infinite
shield charge bug hasn't been fixed yet
but maybe in the future it will be next
is just one game-mode fetch and it's for
skirmish and elimination making it so
that reviving a teammate is a second
longer obviously with the high revive
speed stat it might not matter but who
knows maybe it will I haven't tested it
out just yet up next is a [ __ ] ton of
feats that are being changed the first
one is the revive faster feat is now
faster than before the auto revive feat
which I believe only warlord has he now
spawns you with 50% health instead of
100% body count now gives you less
benefits I don't know what those
benefits are just literally what the
patches just said the conquer feat
health values on block are now changed
from 15 to 5 the fate Luke's feet area
is now increased by 4 meters stun
duration and is now one second longer
and the AoE damage is 25 damage
regardless of the distance you are from
it the healing wind fee which I believe
most vanguards are equipped with now
heals 50 health instead of 40 but it
also has a 60 second cooldown so they
can't spam it midway through a fight the
longbow and the javelin feat damage has
now been reduced from 50 to 80 damage
the crossbow and the throwing axe has
also been reduced from 25 instead of 30
and also has a 60 second cooldown and
finally the kunai also had the damage
nerf from 20 to 15 and also has a 60
second cooldown so basically although
melee all the throwing weapons and
ranged attacks have been reduced in
damage lastly for all the
today the devs had their weekly Q&A
session and to someone all up they
basically are looking into increasing
the chip damage and the zone flicker is
still being worked on but nothing as if
yet and then ranked mode is still coming
very soon I'm predicting either midway
through season two or at the very
beginning of season three that's all the
patches for today I hope you all did
enjoy and if you did give the video a
like if you didn't dislike the video and
then if you're new to the channel please
subscribe for tons of four on our
content I post and hit the bell next to
that so you never miss a video of mine
if you want to see my previous video
click the annotation in the top right
where we talked about the second
blackout event but thank you guys for
watching and I'll see you all in the
next video goodbye guys